from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between wingstop in the uk and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
in the uk we can get wing portions in
four sizes
eight wings 10 wings
12 wings or a flavor craver
wing platter which comes with 24 wings
and three dips u.s wingstop you can get
your wings
in 10 15.
20.
30. and
30. not enough you say i agree
wingstop also does wings in orders of
[Music]
50 75
and of course 100
chicken wings i'm in heaven right now
bury me in these wings
i'm going in
ah i could do better but we got to move
on
sean evans i'm coming for you buddy so
the portion sizes might be pretty
different but what about the wings
themselves
we're going to weigh 10 plain wings in
the uk and do the same in the us
to see how they match up so 10 plane
wings in the uk came to 290 grams which
is an average of 29 grams per wing
oh way higher dude 360 grams i needed my
calculator app
to determine what 360 divided by 10 is
and it is in fact 36 grams wow
so our average is 36 grams per wing here
in the us what about chicken tenders
well in the uk those come in two portion
sizes
has a portion of three or
as a portion of five at wing step in the
us you get your chicken tenders in
orders of
four seven fifteen twenty and thirty
yes i don't know what maniac
is at a wing stop and gets chicken
tenders instead of
wings i get if you like take your like
10 year old there
let's weigh 5 chicken tenders here in
the us
so five plane tenders in the uk weighs
230 grams
200 what way over 300 on this one
we're over 300 and they try to pass this
off as a tender
bigger chunks of meat over here in the
u.s bigger tender
chunks of meat what about a side of
fries well in the uk these come in two
sizes
regular and large
and in the u.s our wingstop fries also
come in two sizes
regular and
large how those look we're gonna wear
them both to see what they come to
[Laughter]
that's not a good look for fries
how do i get this back in
yep also a brick also
a brick and the large portion came to
255 grams
our regular is bigger than your large uk
okay
oh lost fry 400 grams
fountain drinks in the uk come in one
size it's 22 ounces but unfortunately we
weren't able to get one today
wing stop in the u.s you could found
drinks in two sizes
20 ounce and
32 ounce the wingstop we went to did not
have any 32 ounce cups
dips in the uk only come in one size and
it's regular we're gonna weigh a cup of
ranch to see how much we get
dips in the u.s come in two sizes
regular in this absurd
tub look at this first we're gonna weigh
this
the regular size
now the big boy i i couldn't even guess
how much this container weighs
before i do this closer to 300 this is
heavy
this is like a half a bottle of ranch
[Laughter]
bro it is 440.
440 grams of ranch
so fun fact about me i've never actually
had raj before
this is not a common dressing in the uk
it's just not really on menus we prefer
like a
garlic mayonnaise or a ketchup so i'm
about to try my first ever
brunch see how it goes
okay okay i don't know if wingstop ranch
differs to
the classic right you might find in the
states but it's nice if you want like a
kind of
cooling thing with a similar effect to
mayo in that regard but like a little
bit more tang
a bit more seasoning yeah you guys are
doing it well
the biggest thing on the menu in the uk
is this the flavor craver wing platter
you get 24 wings three dips and no other
sides all for a price of 22 pounds 50.
biggest single menu item at the wing
stop in the us is this
the hundred wing party pack okay
obviously you start with 100 wings
you can get up to six different flavors
i just got the same one
four orders of large fries four orders
of veggie sticks
and eight dips this is supposed to feed
13 people
or like you and three of your friends
you can get boneless or
bone-in wings if you go boneless it's
94.39 and if you go all bone-in wings
it's 104
and 19 cents i gotta say i'm generally a
drums guy over a flat skype
i think it's just the shape is great
it's just like a meat lollipop and also
it feels like you get more meat on there
than you do on a flat
no harry no drums are not good flats are
way better you can pull out both bones
you get all the meat off of it for the
drum it's way harder to get the meat off
don't be deceived by that shape
it's less meat flats flats
have a flat head
[Music]
here is everything you will only find on
the menu at a uk wing stop
and here are all the exclusive items you
can get at a us wing stop
we'll start with the chicken there's
actually one flavor of wing we can get
that you guys can't
which is this one it's brazilian citrus
pepper
i'm gonna try the brazilian citrus
pepper using my patented
wing eating technique get one of the
bones up and then little
meat lollipop
nice little freshness from the citrus
kick from the pepper
not bad so for exclusive wing flavors
you can get
these two the bayou barbecue and the
lemon
hot we can also get any wingstop flavor
on the side
i don't know if you can get that in the
uk another thing you can do
at the us wing stop is you can customize
your fries
and you can get regular or extra
seasoning so i got an extra seasoning
of a seasoning you guys don't have in
the uk which is the garlic parmesan
look at the seasoning on this i mean
they just dusted this thing right
you know exactly what i'm going down
yeah
yeah these are louisiana
voodoo fries they are topped with a
cheese sauce
ranch and cajun seasoning our exclusive
fry option
is this sweet potato fries these come in
sizes of regular or large and you can
also get them in the same seasonings as
the regular fries
in my opinion you guys aren't missing
out on much with these i just always
think that sweet potato fries are worse
than regular fries they always cost
more they always come out soggy it's
just not worth it just stay with the
regular
outside of meat and potato you can also
get
cajun fried corn am i saying that right
it's fried
you can also get freshly baked rolls
bread baby bread we also have one other
exclusive side which is this it's a
honey mustard slaw
we can also get booze from our wing
stops this comes in the form of
two types of beer and usually we'll be
able to get two types of wine however
due to a reduced menu
currently they're not serving them the
three drink options you can get in the
us are oddly enough
sweetened and unsweetened tea i don't
know why we have tea in the uk does not
and also you can get this 52 fluid
ounce simply lemonade and finally in the
uk you can finish off your meal with
some churros
these come in portions of either six or
ten
you have two crumb options including
oreo
or lotus biscoff and then you can choose
from one of two sources either a sweet
milk
or some dolce de leche caramel
what about desserts here's one you get
in the u.s and not in the uk at a wing
stop
the triple chocolate chunk brownie
they say that the right order fantastic
i'm not gonna do something really stupid
which is attempt to eat the hottest wing
on the wingstop menu
which is the atomic wing these come with
gloves
just to avoid getting it on your skin
and then getting it in your eyes
i'm not good with spice one thing to
note
ah man i don't really want to do this
but hey
for the content cheers
yep that's immediate
[Music]
oh man
deep breath sorry deep breaths terry's
doing it
i'm doing it too
[Music]
this is a half i'm a tough guy with the
heat this is not that hot
[Music]
yeah sounds hot
[Music]
yeah i'm starting to feel it
ah my tongue's kind of starting to hurt
that's what they do on the uh hot ones
one
[Music]
unfortunately wingstop doesn't disclose
any of its nutritional information in
the uk
they do disclose the nutritional
information in the us however
and there are some pretty interesting
takeaways okay let's start with this
the classic meal for one an eight piece
combo
i got four hot wings four lemon pepper
regular fry
dip regular coke this meal contains a
total of 1595 calories along with a lot
of your daily fat
and sodium allowance interestingly if
you get the same meal but boneless wings
instead
the calories go up to 1711 roughly a
seven percent increase
even more interestingly the sodium in
the meal rockets up to 5258 milligrams
which is 228 percent of your daily
allowance
so it looks like boneless wings are way
saltier than bone in wings but they do
contain
slightly less fat what's the most
calorific wing at wingstop in the us
that would be the boneless garlic
parmesan wing which clocks in at 112
calories
for just one the saltiest wing on the
menu
is the boneless original hot wing now
it's less calorific than the garlic
parmesan but just five of these is your
entire daily sodium allowance
the tenders at wing stop are as you
might expect more calorific than the
ones
the most calorific flavor in the us
garlic parmesan
whoever heard that before that's not the
saltiest thunder
that crown goes to the cajun spice
tender
775 milligrams of sodium just three of
these is your entire daily allowance
i didn't come here to not eat chicken
tenders
what about the dips well the least
healthy dip on the menu is this is honey
mustard
just a regular portion of this in the
u.s contains 367 calories
33 grams of fat 5 grams of saturated fat
682 milligrams of sodium and a slightly
alarming 17 grams of sugar
as for the rest of the menu you really
want to watch out for the fries
the most calorific single menu item on a
wing stop menu
is a large portion of the louisiana
voodoo fries
this serving alone is 910 calories which
is almost half
of your daily allowance if you're
looking to cut down on sodium you might
want to avoid the buffalo ranch fries
they're slightly less calorific from the
louisiana voodoo fries however they
contain 2
80 milligrams of sodium that's 125
percent of your entire daily allowance
in summary wing stop maybe not the
healthiest fast food chain
if you're looking to cut back on your
sodium definitely skip the boneless
wings
and maybe stick to regular fries and not
the ones with these
gross toppings
[Music]
now sadly along with the nutrition
wingstop uk also doesn't disclose its
ingredients
wingstop also does not disclose its
ingredients in the u.s
so what do we know about what goes into
the chicken well for starters in the uk
the chicken is
not organic and not free range all the
chicken they use in the uk is also halal
which means it's suitable for muslim
people to eat
now it is unclear if the us chickens are
free-range or organic
all wing stops say that they expect
their chicken supplier to conform
with usda fda state and local
regulations
however they do not specify a grading so
for all we know it could be grade c
chicken which can be misshapen poorly
fleshed
and jesus and with no limit on the size
number of areas or intensity of
discolorations
and flesh bruises wow i wish i knew that
a few minutes ago
in better news the fact that they refer
to their tenders as tenders
legally means that they have to at least
be made
of whole cuts of chicken breast and
might be actual
chicken tenderloins which are in the
inner pectorial muscles
of the chicken breast and that's pretty
much all we can glean from the
information that's publicly available
why are you so sneaky wing stop is it
because you know we'll eat it regardless
correct
i should have waited before i went in
that second wing